Ricky,
where are you at with your training today?
You now I'm down $902 and how
much money have you made so far?
Uh,
like five bucks.
I think the idea of like what
money means to me, it has changed.
I passed that milestone.
I like becoming a military late 2007
Tim.
I think money doesn't mean too much to me.
I don't think we need as
much of it as we think we do.
People do find it hard to talk
about money because it's so private.
It's like talking about underwear.
Okay.
What is going on everyone? It's Turkey
with a lot of planning profit. Ah,
yesterday covered profits at 63 31 today.
During pre market hours
it hit highs of $69
my name is Reiki Gutierrez. I'm 23 years
old and I live in Gilbert, Arizona.
What I do for living is investing in
the stock market. I'm an influencer.
I own a series of real estate
properties and I run a series of online
businesses.
Do you roughly know how much
weight you make annually? Yeah.
So I've put this year with a different,
probably Chris that we have going on.
I can probably bring in
lights six to 7 million.
My name is Azariah Randall and I'm
21 years old and I live in San Diego,
California.
What do I do for a living?
I primarily deliver food.
Sign up for this food delivery APP.
And how much do you see you make?
Like on average
I can make like easily like a hundred and
hope you guys all have an amazing rest
of your day. Continue working hard,
continue to fall in James.
Let your passion be a in
your success like ours. Guys,
let's make sure that we end the year
on a green note. Take it as a team.
How did you do just in that session?
Um, as in trading, not very good.
So I'm down about 1% in big picture.
Like it's not much,
it's just because I'm right now invested
with about $30,000 boom, boom, boom.
What's going on guys?
I made a mistake and I covered
profits yesterday on you yas and luck.
What I missed out on.
We have these here at the Ra there.
I have my other GGR over there.
I own that house to my favorite part of
the day is working with my private group
and seen the excitement that they
give back is probably one of the most
rewarding things.
My goal is to create a series of
applications that are worth hundreds of
millions if not billions of
dollars. Right. I think if I had
$10 billion in my pocket right now,
I think I would still be the same person.
I have a stronger relationship with
my faith. Matthew six and 21 says,
wherever your treasure is,
the desires of your heart,
we'll be also what is going on everyone.
I'm going to be packaging some
orders for tech with apparel.
She's just saying your parents to Europe.
Yeah,
so they went for I think a total of
like 24 days. Did you buy your trance?
A water thing and you tell me that
they like ass or needs something.
Like I'll be like paying
my little sister's tuition
for our university and then
anytime that they like running low
or something, then I can assess. But
what's up Instagram? You'll look. It's
a good day. We got, we got John here.
He's following me around all day
pretending that my life is interesting.
It might be dirty
and I'm not willing to say
so much beside them is that they should
pay me break. Let's make perfect.
I'm pregnant. This baby it Brett
does make perfect. I'll bring,
this is baby that I miss daisy.
Oh, we got to delivery. We got the text
messages. We're going to the broken yolk.
Will you do the down here on steaks?
Cool.
Got Room for two of us in here.
Hi.
Bye.
Yeah,
no problem.
What's going on? Twitter is how many of
you guys has never won. It's a tracker.
Today's compete with your friends
and see what was the, oh my gosh.
Reiki. Where are you at with your
trading today? Do you know? I'm down.
Oh my God.
I actually more than I thought
$902 you sweat that at all or no,
because like I've been down like $2,000
and I recovers and I make like $3,000 on
it.
So,
so right now as you can see, we don't
have any delivery, so we're waiting,
playing the waiting
game. It's Kinda, it's,
it's like when you text your crush and
then you're waiting for her to text you
back.
But she never does.
Honestly,
I think I messed up in this position.
I'm someone that like I,
I value the dollar so much.
Like you saw me go to chipolte
that and I won't get a drink.
I just became very food or from a very
early age and very aware of how to try to
pick money and the stress that it
brings on and seeing how it acted as a
negative catalyst for my
parents' relationship.
We went to Mcdonald's and I overheard
that by parents weren't doing as well
financially. And my cousin was like, oh,
I want a big Mac and I want large fries.
I like looked at him and I was like,
no, don't get that. Like, you know,
just because of the extra cost.
That's when I really started to,
you don't try to buy it and sell like
snicker bars or power rates just to pay
for myself.
So my parents didn't have to pay me.
Okay.
That one's going to pay like
nine bucks at Asia walk less go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. To dagger
February Seafood Delight.
How's that grows and a egg flour soup.
Yeah.
Awesome.
The order is Hella big.
Waiting round two
when I was growing up we were,
we are good financially up until my age,
like seven I guess I would say that was
when my mom was like a single mom to me
and my two sisters.
We didn't know we were poor or like broke
or anything because my mom did such a
good job of hiding it and just
like grinding and hustling.
But then like growing up I kind of did
understand like our financial hardships,
look how much we got
paid for that 35 bucks.
Cause that's like with the
fat tip and whatnot. Yeah.
It's exciting. So what happened? Um,
she says she's missing an item.
Yes. I'm so sorry. Yes. It's another
part of your order. We have it back here.
There's three salads.
Right. Okay. Thank you.
How many of you guys wants to turn
your passion for cars and to profit?
We are reopening the 30 day mentorship
challenge we sold out last time in three
days. All you have to do now
is swipe up to learn more.
Uh, I got terrible news. They don't have
the tomato and Mozzarella Panini, but
do you have,
so
I think if this building right here
is 20 to 30 yeah,
no problem.
Yeah, it's been super
slow for like an hour. Um,
probably won't get any more orders just
because we're downtown and everybody's
probably like on their way home already
right now. Yeah, we'll just call it a day.
Cool.
Okay.
Do you think the money
defines people to you?
I think, I think in today's world, um,
money definitely does have a,
a huge form of credibility.
I believe money can
define you if you let it.
I don't believe it defines
me personally at all.
I've had like 27 cents in my bank account
and also have had like $3,000 in my
checking account. It was just
like ready to ball out, you know?
And I was the same exact person.
Does money buy happiness?
No actual names or when someone who does
not buy happiness, I try this quick one.
Are you happy? I'd say I know
definitely. I'm very happy with,
there's no reason not to be happy,
right. With where it is that I am. Um,
but there's definitely moments that
feels like kind of, I kind
of know, just like empty.
I think money can't buy happiness,
but it can only buy either temporary
happiness or things that make you happy.
I am. I'm very happy. It's,
it's weird. I'm like smiling,
answering that and like, I like struggle
with depression and stuff, so it's weird,
but it's like,
like I'm very freaking happen.
All right.
You always come through with,
what's your name again?
Can you trace any of
your income from today?
Yeah, with everything. Um, I'd
say probably around about 11,000.
11,000.
Yeah.
So what is it that you like to say?
Oh um, you know, continue working
hard, continue to fall into James,
like your passion, be what your abs
and your success. Um, and like always,
let's make sure that when
the year on every note to go
has Orion. Hey, make some noise
for me if he broke all right,
y'all didn't hesitate it. You're all
getting robbed by the end of this. Yeah.
Today the day we made six while we
were out in like almost five hours,
which is like 12 bucks an hour.
I think minimum wage is like 1150.
I would like to be making more money
and I'm trying to figure out ways to do
that. People have lately been telling me.
I'm funny. I found that out recently. Um,
so that's part of the reason I
started doing standup comedy.
I can definitely make people laugh.
We've got the light hits you. I know,
right? He may have a, but write the check,
right?
The chick,
all my friends that graduated high school
just graduated college and I'm like,
Dang, they broke. They
like 120,000 in debt.
I'm just like 2000 and debt,
you feel me? So we didn't,
we can all read books you don't need like.